dr. strange you think you know how the
world works what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many
this doesn't make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to
through the mystic arts we harness
energy and shape reality
we travel great distances in an instant
if I get from here to there how did you
become a doctor studying practice your
spit
there's a strength to him but is he
ready
be careful which paths you travel down
strange stronger men than you have bust
away
death
and pain
you'll die detective this world
can't do this there is no other way
I've spent so many years
through time
looking for you
but what's this my mantra it's the Wi-Fi
password we're not savages
you
happy comic-con day 4 so we finally got
new Doctor Strange footage benedict
cumberbatch came to comic-con we put on
this huge show so let's break it down so
much better look at the actual magic of
Doctor Strange this is really cool
they're bending space in a very
inception matrix see wait let they're
basically saying that the reality that
we perceive like us normal people or
even someone like Tony Stark or Captain
America or any of the Avengers beyond
Thor Thor in the Asgardians probably
know a little bit about magic but the
way they're shaping reality in the
trailer here makes it seem like like the
waking conscious world is really just a
dream and you can kind of seem as
Mickelson's character takes it to the
edge of destruction like by the end of
the trailer New York turns into this MC
Escher nightmare and you begin to wonder
is they're chasing each other through
the trailer if the normal people on the
street just walking around or perceiving
all these changes the portal effects are
amazing we travel great distances in a
very short amount of time there was a
prequel comic that got a little sciency
about the way it explained like they
basically are manipulating energy from
another dimension so you probably know
some version of his backstory
he's a search like a brilliant surgeon
who's kind of an [ __ ] he's kind of
like a doctor version of Tony Stark they
have a very similar arc they even kind
of look like each other you know which
is why Tony Stark is totally high-fiving
him here magical moustache bros for life
so he gets into an accident and even
though his hands heal they don't heal
well enough for him to perform surgery
anymore so he can't do the thing that
makes him special anymore so he wanders
all over the globe looking for someone
to heal him when he finds the ancient
one
so obviously the movie's gonna have a
version of that you see rachel mcadams
character she's the character that will
connect him to the human world someone
who worked with him before if she's
gonna be another doctor but in the
context of the movie universe she's
really like night nurse she's this
person in New York City that all the
vigilantes all the heroes go to when
they can't go to a real hospital to
protect their identities so we see a
little taste of the sanctum sanctorum we
see the cloak of levitation we see the
eye of agamotto I know a lot of people
are wondering if the time gems in there
because you know based on the way they
explained star Lord's farther and
guardians of galaxies it sounds like the
soul gem might show up in that movie so
I'm guessing if there's a gem in dr.
strange it's gonna wind up being the
time gem this is Wong in the prequel
comic they set it up that he's just
another magician he's not going to be
the manservant that he is in the
he's actually a much bigger character in
the scope of the movie like he's a
full-fledged magician just like Baron
Mordo and just like Maz Mickelson's
character so if you didn't see my last
Doctor Strange video Mads Mikkelsen is
playing the main villain they've since
revealed him - because Silius now he's a
little bit different than the Casillas
character of the comics so you don't
really need to worry about that too much
in the context of the movie like the
prequel comic kind of sets him up he's
part of their order he's one of the more
skilled people in their order but for
unknown reasons he runs afoul of
something in the Dark Dimension and
that's what puts him on this dark path
till he goes full Darth Vader and
becomes the villain that you see in the
movie as is the case with a lot of big
Disney Marvel Star Wars movies
there have been toys sets that have
spoiled some of the big twists in the
movie so you might know about one of the
other big villains from the Doctor
Strange comics that are showing up but
in the way that Ant Man was an origin
story for that character while being
relatively self-contained you know
having a couple links to the Avengers
films like we saw a falcon we saw that
flashback at the beginning that was kind
of like the origin of shield like Hank
Pym was like peace out I'm not working
with Starks so just like that this is
gonna be a relatively self-contained
movie because this is the first time
that we're really learning about magic
in the Marvel Universe there is a little
overlap with Thor but the way he
explains that you know is that magic is
just like science that you haven't
explained yet this kind of magic is
almost the same thing but just kind of
leaning in the other direction like
there probably is a scientific way
within the context of the Marvel
Universe to explain what Doctor Strange
does I'm sure whenever he crosses over
in an actual Avengers movie they'll have
a couple of jokes about that like Tony
Stark will try to figure it out like
okay I'm a scientist I can totally
figure out this magic stuff what's the
trick like when he was trying to lift
Thor's hammer he was like okay like
what's the Sango whoever has the
fingerprints of Thor so I'll be really
interested to see where this movie fits
in in the timeline because there was
that Easter egg and Captain America
Winter Soldier a long time ago that
movie was a while ago where they said
that Stephen strange was a threat
according to Hydra so what I'm expecting
is is that Doctor Strange won't start
crossing over with the Avengers till we
get closer to infinity war till Thanos
starts manipulating reality with the
gems because in the grand context of
things Doctor Strange is like a
protector of all reality he has this
greater responsibility so he doesn't
really micromanage the way The Avengers
do but the other big
and I know a lot of you are asking Baron
Mordo is a very big Doctor Strange
villain so he seems very nice he even
gives him the Wi-Fi password Shambhala
is actually an easter egg for a big
Doctor Strange story that I'll explain
in a second but she would tell ig4 is a
fantastic actor what I think they're
doing is they're just giving future
movies future Doctor Strange movies a
place to go so he's a friend in this
movie that eventually becomes an enemy
so think of him in the way you would
think of Loki when we start out in the
Thor movies like he and Thor brothers
they care about each other but then Loki
learns about his heritage sends him on
this dark path all this resentment
wheels to the surface and he becomes the
villain that he is today so I'm
expecting something similar for Baron
Mordo so when they do start facing off
against each other it'll be a lot more
personal
but just to be clear Baz Mickelson is
the main villain in this film his name
is Cass Ilyas throughout the course of
the film Doctor Strange will become the
fully actualized sorcerer supreme so
like when you see him furling the cape
here that's probably relatively late in
the film like you see the montage of him
doing the cliffs like slowly learning
magic learning in the same way that he
would learn to practice medicine so it's
gonna be a lot of fun and it's
definitely gonna change the way you
perceive the Marvel Universe like the
actual physical universe itself so I
cannot wait to see him introduce himself
to the Avengers and see which of them
just craps their pants and won't it be
awesome to see him pair up with Scarlet
Witch now her magic is a slightly
different thing her power flows from the
mind gem but don't worry like if you're
confused about how all this is going to
work like the logic of it all the movie
will explain it in a really simple
elegant way like it's designed to be
viewed by people who have absolutely no
idea who dr. strange is so don't worry
Shambhala though just to explain that
Easter Egg in the trailer so into
Shambhala is the name of a really big
Doctor Strange story were these
otherworldly beings tell dr. strange
that he can usher in this Golden Age for
Humanity but the twist is is that in
order to achieve that he has to
sacrifice most of humanity
so it's a very Star Trek II type arc
where the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few the needs of the few
outweigh the needs of the many but the
name Shambhala is a reference to the
Lords of Shambhala that's the name of
the otherworldly beings that are like
dr. strange you can usher in this new
golden age but you have to kill pretty
much everybody on the planet to do it so
the funny thing about that story though
is that
scott derrickson the director of the
movie actually tweeted a picture from
that comic book story back in November
of 2014 that was probably when he was
working on writing the movie so it's
just funny to see that Easter egg show
up now years later but let me know what
do you guys think about the trailer it's
definitely a much cooler trailer within
the last one and let me know what you
think about the visual look of magic in
the Marvel Universe I just I can't wait
to see how they integrate it with the
other Avengers stories
so just reminder there's a new round of
the Marvel giveaway going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video what I'm gonna do is there's a
couple more Marvel videos that I have to
make there's Thor Ragnarok there's
guardians of the galaxy - and then
there's a couple more DC trailers that I
need to work through so all that stuff
should post through Monday and Tuesday
so I'll be posting updates on Twitter
and Facebook unlike when videos are
coming but a lot of awesome stuff I was
really happy with the Marvel panel if
you've ever been to Marvel live like
it's a big live event that they put on
it's kind of like a stage production
that's kind of what the actual Marvel
panel was like like they definitely have
a sense for showmanship but next video
should be guardians of the galaxy -
James Gunn revealed a whole bunch of
information it is gonna be the most
awesomely weird Marvel movie ever if you
think Doctor Strange is weird
guardians of the galaxy is gonna be
weird in the best comic book way
definitely my favorite moment was brie
Larson Captain Marvel fangirling on
Doctor Strange Avenger fangirling on
other avenger so y-you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my breakdown of the spider-man
homecoming trailer and you can click
here for like the whole panel
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight